il y a eu évidemment avant que nous
soyons réunis pour cette réforme
d'autres réformes des retraites avant
celle-ci et quel que soit le
gouvernement elles ont tout en commun
deux choses d'abord avoir relevé l'âge
et où la durée de cotisation pour le
premier point et ne jamais avoir été
remise en cause quel que soit les
alternances une fois qu'elles ont été
adoptées elles ont toutes enfin eu comme
priorité le retour à l'équilibre
financier puisque la création de
nouveaux droits et c'est peut-être sur
ce dernier point que cette réforme se
distingue avec cette volonté d'améliorer
le système mais aussi de financer
massivement des nouveaux droits dans une
ampleur sans précédent puisque nous
demandons de travailler plus pour
produire plus en retour nous
retrouverons l'équilibre et nous
financerons ces nouveaux droits je les
dis là aussi inlassablement améliorer
sans équilibrer serait irresponsable et
équilibrer sans améliorer serait injuste
et c'est pourquoi nous voulons faire les
deux de fait sur les 18 les 18 milliards
d'euros que génèrent la mesure d'âge en
2030 un tiers c'est-à-dire 6 milliards
d'euros sont donc consacrés des mesures
de justice et de solidarité
c'est d'ailleurs précisément ce qu'ils
fonde la justification d'une telle
réforme dans un budget rectificatif de
la sécurité sociale puisque l'effet des
différentes mesures en dépense comment
recette sur les branches vieillesse sur
les branches accident du travail à
maladies professionnelles justifie
pleinement le recevabilité dans ce bel
effet SS aussi de leur impact sur les
comptes sociaux de 2023
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
dit peut-être un peu vite tout à l'heure
que cette réforme est une évidence mais
il est vrai que c'est évident c'est
parfois contesté heureusement pour nous
qu'il a défendons il n'y a pas de
meilleur moyen pour s'en convaincre que
de faire le tour rapidement des
alternatives qui lui sont opposés
alternative qui sortent toutes à un mur
de contradiction certains ont proposé
dans une nostalgie qui ne trompe
personne de revenir à la retraite à 60
ans mais sans toucher au 43 annuités
pour avoir le taux plein c'est un
comprendre ça va penser que le projet
derrière cela et de mettre les Français
au travail le plus tôt possible ou leur
proposer un système qui soit une machine
à décote une machine à petite pension et
donc une machine à pauvreté d'autres
proposent de revenir à 60 ans avec 40
années comme 20 ans 20 ans en arrière en
diminuant la durée de cotisation c'est
en réalité nous condamner collectivement
à chercher 85 milliards d'euros de
financement chaque année bon courage
pour cette entreprise
[Musique]